you gave economists a d minus
i'm not even going to ask you what you
give to governments
uh
do you think their failure economist and
government failure is malevolence or
incompetence
i think uh
policymakers are well intentioned but
generally all all government policy is
inflationary and all government it's
inflammatory and inflationary so what i
mean by that is
you know when you have a policy uh
pursuing
uh
supply chain independence if you have an
energy policy if you have a labor policy
if you have a trade policy if you have a
you know any any kind of foreign policy
a domestic policy
a manufacturing policy every one of
these medical policy
every one of these policies
interferes with the free market and and
generally prevents
some rational actor from doing it in a
cheaper more efficient way
so when you layer them
on top of each other they all have to be
paid for
if you want to shut down the entire
economy for a year you have to pay for
it right if you want to fight a war you
have to pay for it
right if you don't want to use oil or
natural gas you have to pay for it if
you don't want to manufacture
semiconductors in china and you want to
manufacture them in the us you got to
pay for if i rebuild the entire supply
chain in pennsylvania and i hire a bunch
of employees and then i unionize the
employees
then not only am i
i idle the factory in the far east it
goes to 50 capacity so so whatever it
sells it has to raise the price on and
then i drive up the cost of labor for
every other manufacturer in the us
because i competing against them
right i'm changing their conditions so
everything gets less efficient
everything gets more expensive
and of course the government couldn't
really pay for
uh its policies and its wars with taxes
we didn't pay for world war one with tax
we didn't pay for world war ii with tax
we didn't pay for vietnam with tax in
fact you know when you trace this what
you realize is the government never pays
for all of its policies with taxes
to ask to raise the taxes to truly
transparently pay for the things you're
doing with taxes with taxpayer money
because they feel that's one
interpretation or it's just too
transparent
if people if people understood the the
the true cost of war
they wouldn't want to go to war if you
were told that you would lose 95 of your
assets you know and 90 of everything you
will be ever will be taken from you
you might
reprioritize your thought about a given
policy and you might not vote for that
politician but you're still saying
incompetence not malevolence
so fundamentally government creates a
bureaucracy of incompetence it's kind of
how you look at it
i think a lack of humility right
like uh like
if if people had more humility then they
would realize uh humility about how
little they know
how little they understand about the
function of complex this is the phrase
from quantities towards movie unforgiven
where he says a man's got to know his
limitations
[Laughter]
i i think that a lot of people
overestimate
what they can accomplish and experience
experience in life causes you
to uh
to re-evaluate that so i mean i've done
a lot of things in my life and and
generally
my mistakes were always my good ideas
that i enthusiastically pursued
to the detriment of my
great ideas that required
150 of my attention
to prosper so i think people pursue too
many good ideas and you know they all
sound good
but there's just a limit to to what you
can accomplish
and everybody underestimates the
challenges
of of implementing an idea
right and uh and they always
overestimate the benefits
of the pursuit of that so i think it's
an overconfidence that causes an over
exuberance and pursuit of policies and
as the ambition of the government
expands so must the currency supply
you know i could say the money survival
let's say the currency supply
you can triple the number of pesos in
the economy
but it doesn't triple
the amount of manufacturing capacity in
the said economy
and it doesn't triple the amount of
assets in the economy it just triples
the pesos so
as you
increase the currency supply
then the price of all those scarce
desirable things will tend to go up
rapidly
and the confidence of uh all of the
institutions the corporations and the
individual actors
and trading partners will will collapse
you